our next question today is from Roger
who says should being an organ donor be
mandatory the so this is an interesting
question because being an organ donor is
optional there are varying opinions
about whether you should be opting in or
out in other words the default be that
everyone's an organ donor unless they
opt out or should default the default be
what it is now which is you are not an
organ donor unless you opt in one of the
more common reasons that people site
against organ donation is because of
freedom of religion you cannot mandate
organ donation since it would go against
the religious beliefs of some religions
and as by its very nature you would have
to at minimum grant religious exemptions
and that caused us a whole other set of
issues freedom of choice is a more
common reason which is were as
individuals were not under an obligation
to allow our bodies to be used to
potentially save other people even
though you could argue that it would be
from from a sort of overall well-being
perspective a better choice that we are
not we have freedom of choice when it
comes to that and slippery slope
arguments are also made which are hey if
you mandate organ donation there could
be all sorts of other unintended
consequences for example groups that go
out and murder people in particular ways
knowing that they could be sort of the
Robin Hood's of organs taking from a
healthy person and maybe saving five or
six unhealthy people I reject that
argument because murder is still against
the law and and we sort of have a
mechanism by which you're not allowed to
just go out and and murder people
there's also a population argument
that's made individuals who are very
skittish about any action which would
drastically accelerate population growth
say you know there's sort of a natural
population limiting effect of only a
fraction of the population
being organ donors and if all of a
sudden every time someone dies you're
potentially saving the lives of multiple
people that is going to put significant
strain on our planet in terms of
resources etc and then there's also the
argument against about medical
malpractice which is there's actually
one of those basic medical ethics
problems the trolley problem as compared
to healthy person comes into the
hospital do you kill them to save five
of your patients that are about to die
if they don't get organ transplants I
actually think Pat that most of those
arguments against are hypothetical and
speculative in a way that doesn't really
address the issue I think the main issue
is that in our current understanding of
society there is no legal justification
for mandating organ donation there's
just i've not seen if you're going to
say organ donation should be mandated
then you need to be able to demonstrate
where the government would get the power
to mandate such a default action and
I've not seen a compelling case that the
government would be within its legal
rights to do that right especially I
think the religious argument is probably
the most sound there because you know
people have a rights to their bodies and
especially if they think there's a
religious reason as to why they have to
keep their organs intact I think that
would hold up quite well in court as to
keep the system the way it is but also
when you die do you really have the same
rights to your body as you do when
you're alive because obviously you can't
control it other people have to pick up
the mess there I think the most
interesting thing you mentioned there
though is do we have the same rights to
our body when we die is when we're alive
because the first argument you made the
religious exemption argument if you can
determine that a certain action is
paramount to public health like for
example the vaccination of kids you can
say as California has said that there
will not be exemptions granted for
children looking to attend public school
for vaccinations on the basis of
religion if you don't want to have your
kids vaccinated they cannot go to public
school and you could make the same
argument that you made just then Pat
about a religious reason not to have
organ donation happen the difference for
me the key difference that you brought
up is do we have the same right to our
body when we die and that is a much more
complicated question because when alive
mandating vaccinations in spite or
despite religious preferences
contradicts the argument you made but
what what is our right to our body when
we die and I think if there is a legal
case to be made for the government being
able to mandate organ donation
my sense is it comes somewhere along
those lines so I think that's a super
super interesting approach and an
interesting way to think about it and to
answer Rodgers question right now I
don't believe that organ donation should
be mandatory